Riley Keough and Priscilla Presley not
speaking as they battle over Lisa
Marie's estate she always knew she
wouldn't be here too long
childhood passes by
with a glimpse of her green eye
she then grew a family of her own
a source tells E.T the two aren't
communicating at this time but have
talked through their lawyers
our heart is broken Lisa we all love you
before her death Lisa Marie seemingly
appointed her daughter as her sole
trustee
she's so level-headed I love her and I
don't know what to say she's much
further advanced than I ever was but
Riley's grandmother Priscilla is
fighting that calling Lisa Marie's most
recent Will invalid since previous
versions included Priscilla it is huge
you know to live under
the the light of someone as big as Elvis
it's a big responsibility now we hear
things have been tense and it's been a
heartbreaking few weeks for the two
quote Riley has been mourning the loss
of her mother and is heartbroken to have
to deal with a trust dispute with a
family member that said we're told
Priscilla's adamant that she has a valid
case all the children
have to have their own life obviously
it's a struggle for them because it's a
huge name to carry our source tells us
Riley's disappointed and would prefer to
settle things privately it's absolutely
100 mine always has been mine Graceland
always will be and when it's no longer
mine it would be my children's the
actress claims her mom would never want
this to turn into a public matter
but her grandmother's convinced old
documents have been forged
as for how Riley's handling the issue
apparently her daughter and husband have
been keeping her in good spirits
[Music]
your first single and it hits number one
how do you stop that plus she's trying
to keep positive as her biggest project
yet Daisy Jones and the six is set to
Premiere soon
we're so happy to be on Tick Tock here
we are check out Riley all smiles as she
joins Tick Tock alongside co-star Sam
Claflin to promote the Prime video
series
everything bring you a wonderful uh
exciting new
gift uh
very well can I ask you a question what
do you think the song's about what do I
think the song is about what the song
what do I think the song that I wrote is
about
[Music]
it's about starting a new life
it's about dreaming of something
different
while Riley gears up for the show's
highly anticipated debut she and
Priscilla are also preparing to appear
in court
but Riley's making it clear her main
wish is to keep the family together and
keep Lisa Marie's Legacy in a positive
light
foreign